so hello everybody I guess we can start
thanks a lot for coming we are going to
talk about fable today favorite subject
to compile absorb to JavaScript so it's
a way to use functional priming in your
wave equations but not only web
applications you will see that we can
also target mobile and also desktop
applications first the boring part we
are going to talk about me I'm Alfonso
Asia Cairo I'm the author of fable by M
actually I don't have a computer
background yeah I can see yeah it's a
boring part I'm sorry I told you I'm
actually a linguist
I'm also Japanese speaker this kind of a
disclaimer so it seems that it's if I
say something really stupid the chances
are very high so please be forgiving I'm
also a creator of fable of course
there's a reason I'm here and I'm
co-author of mastering f-sharp it's a
book edited by plaque pub so if you're
interesting absorb of course I'm going
to recommend you to buy this book and
also I think I'm I know that you are all
wondering that so the perm is natural
okay not on so I'm working on the NSYNC
Dodi this a very cool company we are
doing a really clear I made to reality
stuff and we are using favor there but
before talking out table I would like to
pay again with you do you know this
break the gamut of net visibility is
going to change completely the way we
interact with that on the web and we
have here a little game this is the game
to guess how the co2 emissions have
changed for our country in this in the
20th century and until this year so we
have here United Kingdom what do you
think the co2 emissions have gone up or
down up how much like the beginner in
19th century or higher ok let's like
this let's see now actually it went down
so they are doing a good job
that the good thing or this that here we
have this is for normal users so they
have a graphic very beautiful they can
interact with the mouse they can play
with that but here for power users users
who know a bit about programming or
maybe database in database manipulation
we are here and a language and they can
edit the graphing ourselves so they have
the access to the data it's not only
that the graph and the data are
disconnected they are connected and
polar regions can use this so look at
this we have validation we have here we
have intelligence and if everything is
happening on the browser
let's see another country I know which
country you pull hold on okay
Netherlands actually write exam ok so it
was such Netherlands okay let's go there
hey what do you thing up down down the
middle or very very low me okay let's
ride see you in the middle okay let's
see now actually Netherlands has gone up
but of course these relative so I didn't
take the United Kingdom so we have to
check actually what was the starting
point but yeah it was something like
that
so so this is the gamma dotnet I don't
deal idea and do this break it was so
much better check very great contributor
the F star community but this project is
made with pebble okay these are some
kids there was a contest disk
organization Jaya worldwide which is
making a contest for two kids to create
a syrup company okay and they created
this website to help we are kids okay
you can see in the picture there we are
just kid they created
this website with interactions with maps
to help people know where they should
recycle their glass visa whip-it is
totally responsive so you can read it
very well from your mobile they had the
help of an adult but of course it was a
volunteer work so it had very limited
time and they want the context using the
this web and that made the web is made
with favor this website that was
announced today it's also about
recycling and taking care of the
environment in HT by this company it's
called cash noir sarees and Friends
but it's also very nice website you can
have a look there is video thanks
actually there's some music here I know
you can hear but on this website is also
made with favor so I've seen I've showed
you some examples of a website with
different things the gamma dot NAB this
website that I help kids winner contacts
these are also a website to help
environmental activities in a teen but I
want to add I want to explain to you why
you should be interested in writing
JavaScript of course if you are web
developers you have to write the
front-end part of the web you have to
use JavaScript but this only this not
only interesting for front-end because
JavaScript now runs in many places and
also I like to think of JavaScript
notice the language but as a platform
the same way we are talking about JVM or
dotnet they are not just languages you
have maybe the main language in this
platform Java or C sharp but you have
also other languages so I want to think
of JavaScript as the same there is a
strong competition between the biggest
companies like Mozilla or Microsoft or
Google to create the passage describing
team the best example is v8 it is an
open source JavaScript gene
it's very fast actually the one that
motivated explosive JavaScript because
the JavaScript starts to be a very
performant language for a scripting
language for a dynamic language and this
different gene can be embedded in many
places not only the browser so that's a
reason that now JavaScript runs
everywhere runs from the web runs on the
mobile and runs also on this top with
github electron and there is also a huge
and vibrant community and ecosystem so
these are very interesting place to be
so not only if you are maybe you are
dotnet developers maybe you're
developers for the JVM that is also a
very interesting place to be and also
opens many opportunities but I'm talking
to you about HR about JavaScript and now
if you want to make JavaScript why not
write JavaScript why use abstract ed so
I guess I'm not going to go into much
detail but I guess you already know that
HR is a functional first programming
language and functional programming we
all know all the advantages of
functional programming and one of the
things I like from F sharp also from
Vista its Microsoft's inheritance that
the Microsoft always takes very care of
the support innovators in Visual Studio
but HR took that and also expand it to a
VA or many other aiders so the extra
tooling is really really good and it has
very good support in many meters so I
think this is something very interesting
because you cannot develop an abstract
in the mag in Linux using visual studio
code using Emacs using many of the many
letters of the promise are using and as
a function of Ramin language the focus
is stone immutability and composable
functions and also declarative workflows
use an expression state statements using
pattern matching yourself that's a very
large chance of beats using a recursive
function still for loops okay so this
means that the absorb is a very nice
language to write your code declare
children the same way that some UI
languages like a sam'l for example we
help you write your
I declare okay so and it's a much closer
to for example one where we are writing
a diagram our workflow or algorithm on
the code results in absorb is much
closer to the original idea observe it's
a language is sending for productivity
and correction for productivity I think
is very important it's the something
that makes HR a very good fit to target
JavaScript because it has some kind of
the same spirit the same spirit of vina
language very similar to a scripting
language as language of the had a rebel
since ever since the very beginning a
language the da reduces the distance
between your code and the execution okay
between programming and seeing the
result on the screen and also correction
I think this the main difference with
JavaScript Java scripts are very dynamic
language this can be good sometimes this
can it can be very you can have a lot of
feeling of freedom but at same time many
errors you don't get them until runtime
F has a really good compiler really good
tag checker there is not only in
compiled using the same time at the same
times your writing is giving you
continuously hints on how to improve
your code these are some of the code
some of the each oh sorry that the
support absorb this Australia of course
we have also now light editors like an
add-on or vicious vehicle thanks to the
awesome ionized ascension we also have
image my work colleague uses Emacs so
it's not like a something like it's a
hobby or something like that you can do
professional work using Emacs and
recently we have also writer who's which
support F sharp and assert can be used
for fun that can be used for profit as
the Great Scott sales so I don't know if
you know yet
guess what it's a what the industry
United States the goal unicorn
so very quickly fast rising now Esther
up last year gate was bought by Walmart
by three point three billion dollars in
the largest ever acquisition of an
e-commerce company so I think yes s
Arcana can be used for
profit as well because Jade uses
everything does all this development in
absorb the let's talk about favor fable
first the obvious there was an excerpt
rescue compiler I hope that you already
know that by now
one of the our main guidelines to rider
to output Weaver code that is also
compatible with the new ESC yes 2015
standard so it means glasses import et
levels for example and also we want to
make interrupts with JavaScript tools
and libraries as easy as possible for
example javascript was a good
inspiration for us because even if we're
not like javascript as just a superset
of JavaScript which is something very
good because you can get all the good
sets of JavaScript but we want to make
it a very easy to interact with
JavaScript and not just interact with
the libraries to integrate with whole
ecosystem and we don't want to reinvent
the wheel we don't want to think that we
know better and we want to do we create
a whole new ecosystem we want to
integrate with the 16 solutions that are
already working well and especially we
want to reduce the cognitive load the
community overload of the users I don't
know especially when to get on
functional parameters that do we have to
know so many things I don't know the
prep your interest a functional
programming Java rare double a be
doubled Haskell Catholics are a great
language of course but uh I don't know
it was recently was a serving stagger
flow that said that Haskell was a
language mode used during the weekend
and everybody was really happy
huskily the language multi-user in the
weekends and he was thinking what I
don't want to program during the
weekends I want to do other things I
want to even my family so I don't want
to spend my whole life only reading
books about programming I want to read
other books I want to do all the things
I don't want to explain although always
thinking about monads or the
abstractions or the all complicated
mathematical stuff
I just want to do things ok and I'm sure
for me that's this Anna I think I want
to translate this philosophy also to
fable okay so you can use array
system tools we have the table rebel
who's done better it's owned by n Cade
it's a very mysterious person we all
know who he or she is in the HR
community that are just PR this rebel so
you can actually see it here very simple
first we have there's a hello world we
can have more complicated code can you
see it well it's um so you can play with
that this is the easiest way if you want
to give a favor a try a quick try you
can just go to fable dot i rebel HTML
and you can just play with it and this
is video selection during in silverlight
you need class do and this is not going
to a server okay this is happening
everything on the browser how is it
happening because fable has compiled x
our compiler and fable itself to
javascript and you can see here for
example we are using the a factorial
recursive function and we are just
converting it to a while loop so this
the tail call optimization we have also
a sloka solver made by my smart guy that
are treated this to sob Salukis and you
can also see the response here and you
can see that actually the code the
JavaScript code is really readable okay
so even if you have to debug or you have
to modify the JavaScript code you
shouldn't have any problem
so that's our intention we want to
integrate figure into rate which are
with.net SDK so within you to donate SDK
that makes it very easy today I know
that if you have been into development
of net core sometimes a bit crazy
because things are changing very fast
but I'm confident that they're in the
right direction because now you don't
depend on Visual Studio for everything
you just have the comment line and you
with a few comments you can install
templates you can start a break and you
can run everything very easily but still
Microsoft has something there are some
things that the it doesn't does it
doesn't do very well like many jean
packages for nigut so thankful we have
packet and we are integrating with
packet to many also a favor libraries
and also with yarn to manage the
tendency on the JavaScript side we enter
with the Mabel Mabel maybe if you have
done some JavaScript development you
know varied bevel is also a transpiler
from modern JavaScript to all JavaScript
or a JavaScript that is compatible with
more browsers ok and we are using babel
that's the reason of the name table we
are using be able to output the code
they will just translate the ASC the
absence is extreme from the HR source
code and it outputs its aim is to be
able and Babel
does the code generation that's the
reason that this is such a beautiful God
because Babel is a tool used by so so
many people and in works really really
well so why should we do be doing this
ourselves
because this is the beautifulness of the
open source world that we can just
integrate with other tools and we can
take advantage of things that are
already working well and of course we
are interesting with web pad web pack
maybe also you know that it's a bundler
but also he has many things and one of
the most important things that allows
you to do is hot reloading hot reloading
all the themes this is something now
very important I changed completely the
way that you develop because when you
are using a
language like a dotnet language you have
to wait all the time every time that you
make a change you have to wait compile
you have to see we are this better and
better the compiled times are down so
it's not that bad but still it's a it
breaks your workflow you are just trying
to do something you want to try
something very quickly you want to see
how it's looking on the screen and you
want to see it immediately mm-hmm okay
what that allows you to that let's see
an example about that so here you see
the this simple application made by this
guy Eric novellas and you have here the
red mean isolated the the github
repository so you can download it and
because I really don't know the
dependencies for you you only have to
start fable fable actually you'll see
now fable is a it's coming in the break
file we are using also the new project
file and it's coming for that it means
that that you don't have to install it
in your computer it will be pulled by
the dotnet SDK automatically okay so the
only dependencies you need is the SDK
and no J's and maybe young as well you
can see here that we have the code is
very simple it's a bit longer than 100
lines of code and it is a very nice
effect you can see below that also the
the application is the way compiled you
see this is Vsauce real code with the
ionized attention and you can see all
the things that we have we have
intelligence we have taken on the goal
we have also taken for all the reference
we are using the html5 context a canvas
and you can see in the context here we
have all intelligence for all the API
from the browser so now let's try to
have a look and how it looks on the
screen because web pack gives us a
static server so it's something for fun
ok this was known in one hour ok but uh
in our workshop our fable by a guy who
didn't do any JavaScript at all we can
say for example you see is just saving
and recompiling and the browser is
refreshing automatically and we can have
more particles we can have 2,000
particles we can stop updating the
x-axis and then we get this because so
we are not updating the x-axis anymore
but I'm talking also about the
integration with JavaScript so let's
take what will happen if instead of
using this now first story because this
video I have to remember the workflow
this is me making a round circle again
and let's see how to debug the XR code
jiggly and the browser now we are on
chrome devtools and you can see that we
have the XR code there we can set a
breakpoint we can take even the types T
ugly in the browser we can we can check
the value of the of the variables as you
can see we can see the particular array
we can investigate each of the particles
and you see the names are very very
similar additional name mangling we can
see everything very very clearly we can
just go through the debugger so the
source maps are not perfect we have to
prove them but it's they are there so
you can debug the EXR code in your
browser we can try now to comment out
the absorb function and you see that now
we are importing a function from a
javascript file so we have this update
particle function is now happening from
here we just take again and nothing's
happening why because that function the
JavaScript function is the same right is
it doing the same thing but we can now
modify the JavaScript function and will
see the changes on screen now we are not
updating the y-axis okay so we see a
sense that this means that which you can
integrate favor in your JavaScript
project without any hassle this is
integration at the file level it's not a
library level ok you see
that we are importing directly from the
file and now we are using this update a
velocity from the JavaScript file that
is coming from the excel file so these
informations comes both ways but you
coming from observe to JavaScript from
JavaScript or observe and also from a
observe to JavaScript so now you can see
that we can update this function in the
Xserve side and if making a change also
in the JavaScript side and as you can
see there is no name mangly now we can
just use the name of the function G
eclis in JavaScript and just to show a
quick example of the good things about
the F sharp as you can see here now we
are using thin twenty thousand particles
and since start to go very slowly if you
are developing a game you don't want
this okay do you want if you want to you
want the game to still be fast even if
you have to drop some frames so we have
a nice nice function here which is
called request animation frame and this
function in the browser with or with
only call itself when there is a new
frame available this is very good so in
one a load to mash the CPU but the
problem that is the this dysfunctional
only takes up load which is the current
time okay so now as you can see here
oops
no sorry code on
so you'll see that right now we are
stating the we are hard-coding their
time except we are not in it so this
means that the the particles are going
to are going to change the same even if
the frames are very far apart we don't
want that so we are going now to make
the change the negative function feed
itself the last time and thanks to
thanks to a partial obligation we don't
have to do any change for that just feed
the last time drag into the function
just use it to calculate the difference
and now everything goes matches mutter
okay so still we have less frames of
course because there are too many too
many particles on the screen but they
are not making our game or application
it slower these are cool thing about
observe but it's not only about this is
the secret of table and the success of
table has been thanks to its community
we have now several libraries I hope
that in the near future we'll even have
more these were resin fill remoting we
celebrate to make 8tp api's jiggly just
by defining you just define on the
server side on the suave using a suave
server-side you can just define a record
with a function and you can call it
directly from the client side but this
is actually you'll have to be the post I
recommend you to that but this actually
an HTTP API happening there so you can
write your HTTP IP is very very easily
by the way table is not tied to any
several favorite is a pure JavaScript X
our JavaScript compiler but of course is
it plays very well with absorbing the
backend and also plays very smoothly
with Slava ok smoothly I don't know if
you get that it's woven
okay so that we also have the templates
for example to make a feral an
application using suave in the backend
and fable in the front-end we have a
scalpel here that was also committee
driven and we have also a lot of support
from the community and try to give the
ball to github but there are also other
community members that they are very
quick to respond
we are also again a room that is always
most of the times there are people there
that they are able to respond to your
questions very quickly and we have also
blogs we have simples we have tutorials
and you can go to the awesome table
repository that are there's a list of
all the resources the main resources
available for favor I think one of the
best examples of this idea of not
dividing by but uniting and conquer okay
divide and conquer
we try to unite and conquer and one of
the business symbols it's one of the
most popular libraries for fable which
is called favorite Elvis favor Elvis
taking the Elm architecture so imagine
that you can take the Elm architecture
you can use the power and the
flexibility or the observe language and
you can just use react components
because react also has a really big
community and there are many components
available you need a calendar there is
it you need something to manage a
complicated layout in your web
application you can go to react the rot
and it's there
so this wood pebble Elm is twin
I'm not going to go into much detail
because there is another talk right
after this one but don't buy a seven and
I recommend you to go there because
he'll will Spain the Elm architecture
better than me but we are going to see a
very quick example also and this also I
want to show you how easy is to start
developing with fable because we have
now with the donators decay we have the
template templates we have some
predefined in the donated CKD but you
can see here if you don't have in your
computer you can just download them
mm-hmm
you have to I don't have to do that but
you can do that and then we can just
create a new application as you can see
here and go into there you can do go to
the dxtory
and you see all the files that way there
I'm going to go to another one I just
created because I already installed the
appendices there so you don't have to
stare at the screen while the businesses
are downloading but this is same as you
get just by typing net fable a dozen a
new favorite Elvis react okay again you
have these notches here we don't have to
we can install the dependencies but
because they are ready so they will
download very quickly so step for nugget
so you get a bit of slow as usual we
have this this common donate fable npm
run star which is actually because they
will have to sauce it has a dotnet salt
I have the Java scripts all with the
integration with the web pack and Babel
and they have to communicate so doesn't
it it's going to donate SDK is going to
call fable the command line tool and
paywall is going to call NPM ok the NPM
script which is going to go also to web
packet development server it everything
can be a bit complicated better actually
everything there so you have to worry
about that so now we can we unloaded our
dependencies we can just run fable again
you can see here fable is on the break
so June have to install it globally you
can just manage using packet and also
the FS profile you can manage the exact
person that you want to use for a
specific project
it means that you are hovering and then
you have to update fable for another
break it won't create any conflict okay
so I think something very very good so
as you can see here again Stephan will
go into detail but you can see here we
have a a division between the state
between the types which is basically the
model and also the messages that are
sending that are being sent to the
update function to update the model and
have also here this is the view okay if
you know a be able react on JSX
please something very similar but that
you we don't need a new language because
the observe is expressive enough to
declare language and as you can see here
we are just making oops sorry
[Music]
as you can see here the the views are
simple functions so this is the most
powerful template language for creating
HTML because this code itself we can
just a color function and add view can
be a function itself and it's very very
easy to compose so here we are pretty
now a button with some with events with
some Italian as you can see here again
we have intelligence for all this talent
that we can use with CSS and also of
course we have type checking in this
case with can accept both a number on
one stream so it's ok bad for example
for something like a class name if we
try to feed a an integer is going to
complain and very quickly as you can see
here as you it's complaining a merely
you'll have to wait until compile time
thanks to the ionized attention again
and epsilon compiler of course so now
we'll go to the to the browser we'll
have a look and we have a very simple
very simple application that maybe it's
a single page application so if there is
navigation but these navigation is all
happening the on the front end and it's
me this means that we can assert the
navigation also in essay and as you can
see here now we can just make a change
save and if you see below this is the
web pack already detected the change and
it's recompiling i'm is just refreshing
our browser automatically suggest
amazing that you're just developing your
just focus on your editor and then
everything refreshing the browser is
taking care for you we have a very
simple function here to update our shape
just a counter this is the classical
dislike a hello world for this kind of
elm is application so we can change the
update function and say now we want to
add 10 every time that we we want to
press a class one button so you see the
already happen but you know I really
like and I the thing that is very
important about being able to integrate
with JavaScript tools is that the devil
script now they have remodeling tools
for development it has the they have of
course it's hole reloading scene but
they have also tools like a react has an
extension for chrome that lets you see
the virtual Dom because as you see the
defensive that you we are creating this
are creating a virtual Dom so it's a bit
difficult to see the real dumb sometimes
and thanks to this extension we can just
see the virtual DOM and you see again
that everything is matching so in this
case we have the properties that we are
passing to the Advocate to the view that
we can see them also in the browser and
debug them in the chrome dev tools but
there is also notes what I love it and
this without sub tools they stole it
with ads because it was originally for
with AXA applications but now you can
use it many in many places and also with
fable or famous application and this is
time travelling debugging so because we
are using an emotive real estate so
every time that we want to update the
state we just send a message to the
update function and we feed the state
again to the view functions we don't
have to worry about any Motability in
the state we ingest save a snapshot
every time that we want to that we are a
datum state and then we can just replay
everything that we've been doing imagine
what it does for debugging that some
tester is debugging something if the
cover shavax
and then they can just save the steps
they've done and send it to the
developer okay so you can reproduce
exactly what the user did to create the
bug and as you can see here even the
navigation is being stored in the state
so we can just go back in time as you
can see here just by going back in time
we're undoing the navigation
10 any questions so far
and there you told me that you're going
to interrupt me all the time now ok ok I
guess you weren't expecting that
ok ok ok so this is a good time right ok
thanks ok and yeah we've been talking
about some products and they've been
doing with sale but what I wanted to
tell you is that favors not only for
hobby apps this been this array being
used in production ok
it's been used for kazna this a company
that created the website I saw at the
beginning is being used by MSU solutions
is being used by iron I'd ionized is the
extension that is been powering the
extra development will be socio code an
atom that you've seen how is develop
absorber now in a lightweight editor
like if you saw Co code and this
extension is being written absorb and
compiled to JavaScript because we saw
students code ascension have to be
written in JavaScript so this is using
fable as well pro lucid is a Canadian
company Eugene the author of parallel
miss works there and they are using
table as well and and think again my
company we are using favor as well also
they are job offers in favor I don't
know I'm not taking originally I'm very
happy my job so I'm not taking many job
sites but I'm taking Twitter and these
are job offers that are about fable
actually the first one I took it myself
so this one is taken by the the other
one is very the other one is very reason
and I I don't I don't actually know what
happened I I hope the does somebody took
it on and yes so you can see that the
the company's re a trans in F sharp and
fable to do their web apps but I'm I'm
telling you reasons the companies are
using fable reasons that why you should
use fable but maybe you're interested
also in why I wrote favor okay so this
is not out of hate of JavaScript that
sometimes
when we write the language to compile
service fees because we see no
JavaScript Sox is really terrible
actually like JavaScript but I like
f-sharp more okay I like I like the
tools I like the community I think it's
a very very productive language I think
you can do functional priming without
having to think all the time of taking
monarchs or 20 year transducer or things
like this the details helps a lot I
begin I was using visual visual studio
but then I discovered visual field code
anion ID and it was really really
wonderful really wonderful experience so
I started more or less f-sharp and web
development at the same time I was
thinking two ways to combine both of
them I discovered punished at the
time I was contributing transcript but
then there were some developments like
EPS our compiler services to read and
parse devs our source code and they were
also Babel which could do the same so I
thought that it will be very nice to
combine both of them just putting
something in between and make a compile
to JavaScript so this happened like a 1
year half ago I started December 2015
they were like three crazy months of
development then I really saw a very
productive person with multiple bugs but
it was it had a very good welcome from
the community and many people give me a
gave me feedback and they were very
happy to use it
Tomas Berdych created the gamma dotnet
with one of the first versions fable
we're releasing very quickly I was
getting feedback from people
contributing we're releasing zero point
on X versions very quickly and last
couple of Mount release the beta version
of favorite 1.0 mm-hmm this been a
really great journey for me it's been
not only the drama of people said but
the meeting new people being a member of
the absurd community which is a
committee I really loved and also being
invited are places like places like this
like an incredible conferences like MDC
Bera
all journeys must have a goal and the
goal of all software products is
you release several versions and for
several with having today and I'm really
happy using in the hint so if you're
interested in stable we are will be
having the pebble clump we will be
something more familiar much much
smaller than NGC of course this we this
will be the first time that the federal
community is going to gather on the same
group in a book though this call we were
thinking of using a pebble people
complain or maybe cheese's wine a
functional parameter which is what are
we are in with the explain the intention
we have to do actually so if you want to
come you are mother invited you can get
your ticket it's a very very cheap just
to cover the venue and the meal which is
going to be a very good French meal I
promise and you can use the stone code
only for this quick so you need to be
quick and not think very much this NDC
Oslo and that's all for me thanks a lot
for listening I hope the ginger a lot of
the conference and are you have
questions I'm more than happy to take
them and of course I now if you want to
to to bore me when I'm around I'm also
very happy so I don't know if you have
any questions I can also show some code
because I just I was just writing now I
was writing the video because to so to
avoid problems during the presentation
but now if you want I can show you a
demo for example for react native if
you're interested oh oh no I'm open I am
I'm inspecting I was i finished faster
because I was speaking in undress
interruptions and there is no
interruption
but in my head this what's happening at
the beginning the sound test now I think
I doesn't fit very well there soon okay
it flamingos very serious okay yeah
sorry Varick hey ha ha very good hey we
have I have to admit the disfavor remote
in our library is very Britain so I
didn't train myself very much but we
have this failed ball back and this is
also yeah sorry so the question was if
we can show an example about the using a
HTTP request and how it works with a
privacy sign I think so if you know a
bit other sharp and observed usually
have a zinc which is more or less
similar to tasks in c-sharp and but in
the absorb in JavaScript they have
promises so we can you can choose with a
table you can choose either to use async
we are compatible with acing by the way
we are not compatible with the whole the
whole VCL that you can see here you can
go to the docks and you can see here all
the types that we are supporting ok so
this is also very important because we
don't want to embed any runtime we don't
want to we don't want to put a lot of
code in your application so we are our
politics instead you have to pay only
what you need so we are using a ESC yes
2015 modes this means that we can use
key shaking this means that when you are
using your app for production if you
want to minify you get rid of everything
that you need so here you can see in the
documentation for example we are trying
to be as performance possible so when
possible we just use the native
JavaScript type but at the same time we
are keeping the dotnet semantics so for
examples you can use
regular expressions you can use that
time but you'll get the same results as
in C sharp and or.net sorry
please don't accuse me of making the
equivalence of fish are abundant then
okay so if you go to a favor repository
you can go to the test and you can see
here for example you have the date time
and this place all these days all these
we have now more than 100 these are run
every time that we make a atomic these
are run for JavaScript and dotnet so we
are sure that the same semantics is
being kept and of course we have async
teardown that Henry was asking about
that because a thing is works a bit
different to JavaScript promises you may
want to use promise exactly with
anything you have like a rubber so in
some cases you prefer you may prefer to
use promises lately for example when
using the page API in the new API for
some browsers that it's working actually
very nice we have this fable power pack
and here
here you can see that we have also
computations present for promises so it
means that you can use more or less the
same syntax using a something like a
weight for example for promises in
JavaScript as well
this means javascript for example now
they want to add support for promises
but they have to add it directly in the
core language so again you have to wait
until babble acepted with you as to well
until the browser's upset them but with
F sharp we can define or custom
computation expression so we don't have
to wait until the language changes we
can do to change this by yourself by Oh
sauce with just a library so I hope this
answers your question
Henrick back here we have a examples for
using pet in Firebug so here for example
is an example of how to how to download
a web page we just here you can see we
just want to get the length of our web
page we just feed the the URL and then
we get it we have two options we can use
either the computation expression so we
have this syntax like here or we can
just use well waste for a mean
so just a more similar to link for
example just to link lambdas to chain
lambdas and you can see here as well how
easy is to make a parallel request
hmm we can just add from is parallel and
then we get the results in our array
again here we can we get a result with
we can catch the exception or we can use
actually things here yeah we can use
stray pet enter pets will return a
result type which means that we it's
forcing us to check if the request was
successful or not
so this is the way that we can use the
fit the page API is an browser API so
it's not something from favor the favor
but the only way the only thing that it
does just to provide a very simple way
to add innovative way to handle them in
JavaScript in episode sorry but it means
that you are not just bringing a huge
library only for convenience because you
are using directly the API phone the
browser so it's more performant that
having our own library because of the
browser are implementing C++ and they
are really performant but at the same
time you can use all the benefits of the
clean F star syntax so here for example
you can see how are you using the
computation expression for promises so
you see everything here for and return
everything here is happening
asynchronously but we can treat it as if
the word synchronous code so I hope this
answers your question again I know
anybody else has any other question
anything we want to see maybe because
yeah
first we I started so we have this
fabled core library which is more or
less the replacement for F chart core so
when possible we try to align code and
we try to use the native counterpart so
it's a modern performance so for example
for a race we just use JavaScript arrays
but then we have also a favor call for
since that they are not provided by
javascript native libraries and this is
written first in JavaScript then we move
to JavaScript and then now because uh
yeah we are improving the federal
workflow we are going to start writing
the the favorite color code in absorb
itself and then compiling to JavaScript
actually some a couple of models for
example we can use big integrals in a
using table this was and the maps and
the seats they were written in observe
and then compiled to JavaScript using
favor but what it was done ahead of time
so it means that if you go to a
repository there the you'll see for
example so
yeah all this stuff this actually this
Commissioner I took it from from final
script which is actually what's taking
it from the F star core itself so yeah
in this case for the map F star map of F
star set we're just taking more or less
the same code as in the F circle library
and then compile it to JavaScript that
you can see here this is a favor call a
break everything here so now that you
have any other questions maybe we have
time for the reactivity noise taking a
risk live coding mm-hm
as we did our pride before coming to
Oslo after midnight so it can be a
really big big fail the main problem is
that okay it's a pregnant if we're going
to use fear so you know few site reviews
we develop here in Oslo it's another - a
similar tool to create mobile
applications using javascript and I'm
going to use it because with react
native I have to start the Android
emulator it's a bit slow so maybe you
can get bored so let's go for
[Music]
this these bandits were created by Dave
Thomas who was playing with a fuse I
didn't know fuse before I have played
only a little bit it's a very
interesting tool it's just a truly small
focus on on designers because you have
these some this some like markup
language that is using yeah it's - in
most of the UI stuff and then for
example this is a very very simple
example the the logic is really really
small you can see here just less than a
few lines of code that is really Justin
because it works very fast so you have
to again you have here the instructions
you have to install a few tools you have
to go on the break you have to solder
the dependencies and then again just
called fable and run and npm script in
this case because it's a mine okay
in this case because we have to choose
we have the fuse and we have a fable
compiler so we have to use two different
two different terminals one for fuse and
deal for 500 miles but still we have the
same hot reloading experience and this
in a while okay this is going to now
you're going to see is emulator this
always in the presentation so l it's
happening fast okay good
so you can see here it's a very simple
application as most of the the scenes
are being defined the XML like the UX
language they call it this markup
language but we can still define some
things are this being used more than
that we adnetik which is using more like
this Elm architecture here we are using
of zeros so it's closer to the
functional reactive roaming by edema by
we can if you have a look here we have
Phoenix on the screen then we can focus
again on the this we are using also web
back here so we can now say it's already
happening and you can see here how fast
it is done
it's a braving a baby and this an iPhone
simulator is similar that it means that
you can do Android and iOS applications
also very easily using fable
go to NBC okay
yes agree so it's also a really good way
a really nice workflow for your mobile
or web apps
anything else we have five minutes 15
odd sorry so basically that is some JSON
bindings so the way that we for example
you were seeing this the context the
canvas API that we have intelligent we
are taking the data script declaration
files and we are converting them we are
treating them to a sharp and then we can
just use them to give the intelligence
everything but then we have some
metadata that will convert this course
to importance presence in our in
JavaScript so it means that in the in in
JavaScript JavaScript bundle this code
instead of going to observe is going to
call actually the actual JavaScript
library but you don't need learn even in
this so in this case you can see it here
[Music]
so as you can see here this partly
automated and partly manually deleted
but then we can have like a just
interfaces and then we tell where these
interfaces should be imported from and
this whether it's going to be
transmitted to web pack and the web pack
will know where to get the most from and
then sometimes when we have to something
we have we want to have something in in
a special metal method in f-sharp but uh
it actually has to be translated so
something different in JavaScript we can
just omit the script code directly and
also again in the documentation you can
see the way to interact with JavaScript
you can even use dynamic parameter so
you have to if you don't have these
bindings declare in front some files you
can still pull a double script file and
then just interact dynamically with it
you can just define simple interfaces to
interact in a more type safe way with
foreign libraries you can use these
special attributes like Emmet or like a
import to it here or also important
special so you can just actually the in
the previous example do so that we were
in importing these updates of article
function where just important directly
from the JavaScript file if you know it
this is the new XML script 6 2015
modules so they work with imports and
exports so they are fixing one of the
longest one of the biggest problems
javascript that didn't have models so
people had to do many hacks to create
these models in JavaScript but avoid
that everything was global okay
and you can see also here how can we
call F sir code from JavaScript we have
also things like help us for Jason's
relief ISM and Saeed also wrote an
article to explain other way to interact
with JavaScript from favor so you can
see again this is a bit outdated we have
to because this is the previous version
of Abel which had actually a
command-line tool but now we are
interacting with web pack so it's a bit
different but yeah now that we just
final release the civil person we can
focus on the documentation on the
samples by the way you have already a
lot of samples here you have very funny
games we also we are applications that
directly using real for example without
Elvis and doing testing which can have
visualization here using for example
this is three years which is a tool to
to do 3d graphics in the web and you
have all the code is commented here you
should observe formatting by the way I
didn't show you the table Elm inside
which is really nice and it's made with
Elvis itself it's a they're still
changing a bit the styling so it's going
to take probably but the Europe also
samples here and the dogs also are very
good you can go to different leverage
also we can Elvis and you can see how
can you interact with armies
so that's all as you know we can finish
here now of course I'd be more than
happy to answer any question that you
can have just were me there when it's
time to take a coffee or just anything
our the hit mean in Twitter or github in
the failed compiler just we are the
grill ate so just fail compiler or some
sriracha Caro and you'll get me I can
escape so thanks a lot for coming and I
hope you enjoy the rest of campus